tras la polémica por la aprobación de la
Reforma de la jubilaciones en Francia el
presidente Manuel macron y su gobierno
quieren retomar el contacto con los
franceses y por eso hoy ha decidido
realizar una nueva visita en terreno
después de apenas dos que ha hecho
durante estos tres meses que ha durado
la protesta en contra de la Reforma de
la jubilaciones y lo hizo para hablar
del trabajo una de las tres prioridades
que el fijó en el discurso que dio el
pasado día lunes como prioridades de su
gobierno a partir de hoy después de esa
polémica crisis social el presidente
Manuel macronna visitó una empresa
familiar en un pequeño poblado de
alsacia además de dos mil personas dicen
sus críticos que es una visita muy
controlada desde el palacio del Eliseo
pues es una visita de carta postal una
empresa familiar que se dedica a la
construcción en madera que tiene que ver
justamente con la transición ecológica
en la construcción una empresa
innovadora que tiene cerca de
trabajadores allí justamente quería
hablar del tema del trabajo pero no pudo
evitar que lo esperaban personas que se
oponen todavía al proyecto de la Reforma
de la jubilaciones con carteles con Yupi
Ándate En referencia a su sobrenombre de
Júpiter el presidente Rey Emmanuel
macron criticado por las clases más
populares y también a cien días pero no
con nosotros En referencia a ese nuevo
lema del gobierno de Manuel macron de
los cien días de acción que ha dado a su
primera ministra Elizabeth bueno para
atacar los que dicen ellos son los
problemas de Francia más importantes en
este momento es un terreno fácil el de
alsacia Sin embargo el presidente va a
continuar mañana su gira hablando de
estas prioridades irá al departamento de
legó en el sur de Francia allá va a
visitar una escuela en la ciudad de
gunsra es una zona que vota
tradicionalmente extrema derecha por lo
tanto no debería estar tan cómodo como
hoy en alsacia